hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar applying
a closed
modular semi-automated system to car
t-cell therapy manufacturing
i am jennifer woods of labries and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labries and brought to you
by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
yongshae
g phd process development manager
and the cell and gene therapy group at
thermo fisher scientific
dr g you may now begin your presentation
hi my name is jung chung ji i'm the
manager of
cell engine therapy at summer facial
scientific
today i walk you through
some official workflow solution for
a closed modular semi-automatic
system to carti cell therapy
manufacturing
because the novelty of the cell therapy
field
and the inherent
living cell characteristics
of the product the field facing a lot of
challenges from management of
supply chain logistics and you know to
um by processing how do we scale up and
scale
out and all the way to you know
consistency
how do we manage the quality and
performance of the product
and plus there are numerous
of new technologies rapidly
appear and people apply into their
processes
now if i were to summarize all these
challenges
all these are bond down to the
manufacturing
and there's a saying you know
in autologous cell therapy field the
process
ate the product
let's look at some of the manufacturing
issues facing
autologous t-cell therapy
on the left here is a typical workflow
of the t-cell therapy and they start
with
patients at hospital collecting the
blood
uh in the process called glucophoresis
and then this blood will shape to the
manufacturing
facility which is different location
normally
and t-cell can undergo
manipulations modifications
and then it's modified this modified
t-cells
will then ship back to the hospital
and get an administrator to the patient
if you look at the whole process it's
rather
very academic and a lot of
hands-on labor intensive
and people use a lot of open
processes and this
this process is very complex and uh
it used a lot of a different product
and the instrument applied in this
process normally are not flexible to
use to be used in other processes
so this is where we think you know to
solve all this problem
a closed modular and automation system
will help to facilitate
and thermal fissure scientific has the
largest
scientific tools collection
in the world and we ask ourselves how
can we contribute to the cell therapy
field
when we look at internally we have the
largest collection of
regent and protocols and we have
existing cell processing platforms
and the new technology the company with
that
and we have world-class analytical
in-process
tests also we have the capacity of
digital science to integrate the whole
thing and
we think why can't we integrate all
these capabilities
into one workflow to serve the cell
therapy
and by doing that we create modules of
unit
operations each unit or modules
can operate independent of each other
however on top of each module
there is a software library connected to
what we call the brain which is the dirt
of a
system so by using dirt away
we can connect this individual modules
into a whole workflow solution
now i would like to introduce our
thermofisher solutions
step by step here the illustration of a
typical
one two one process so the lupus is
product
arriving at the manufacturing facility
they got washed
and then um t-cells are selected
and these t-cells selected t-cell are
they undergo activation after
certain periods of activation uh
there will be a card being transferred
into these t
cells the gene transfer can be done
either by length virus or
elaboration for today's
seminar i will focus on the elaboration
part
and after the gene transfer these t
cells are expanded to achieve
certain uh cell number in order to dose
the patient
and then the expanded sales will be
washed and formulated uh fair finish
to ship back to the hospital and in the
whole process
we identified several customer pinpoints
namely uh the pbmc isolation step
and tcl isolation step uh how do we
prepare
sales before elaboration and how
to achieve good gene editing efficiency
and i will uh illustrate in this uh
10.1 pinpoint uh one by one
in later of the talks
the first step is normally a pbmc
isolation step
because normally the incoming lupus
is product contains dmso
that need to be washed away and also
other factors including you know the
platelet or
red blood cells that might interfere
with the later isolation
step which also need to be washed away
to solve this problem we invent the
rotia system
it is closed and automated
it has more footprint and comes with its
own
single use consumables
on the right here we see the rotia cell
processing chamber
rotia the underlying principle
is a counter flow centrifuge
which means we introduce a flow force
that against the g-force once the
flow force and g-force equilibrate
the cells are floating in the chamber
and create a fluidized cell bed
and you can imagine with different cell
size and
buoyancy we can easily separate
a different cell populations and in this
case you
we are seeing a small cell bed are
forming
at the tip of cone and as we load more
sales into the cone the bed will grow
much bigger
this is some of the example we use right
here
to do a pbmc isolation
on the left here
top is before rotia processing we have
a lot of red blood cells after routil
processing
we have on the bottom here we have
minimal red blood cells
and the t-cell proportion got enraged
not only that we actually
grow those cells to the right here we
grow those cells compared to manual
phycoisolasis t cells and
both the growth and the immunophenol
type
match very well in both populations
moving to the next step t-cell selection
to do that we use tds
dynamics cd3 td-28
and in combination with a dynamic
magnet and the good
thing for the diamond beads is that it
don't not only
select the t cells but also activate the
t cell
so by using the the database
you achieve the selection and activation
uh two in one
and the data here shows we got very high
positive recovery after
tcl selection average 93 percent
and those uh t cell uh
subpopulation uh cd4 cd8 doesn't change
before processing after processing
while we are doing this process many
many times
we kind of ask ourselves
can we improve this process so in this
example
we combine the pbmc isolation
and the t cell selection activation
step in one step only using row tier
to process this module
in this case we have the logo pack the
incubation bag and
we add a small rocker behind the
rotia in order to do the mixing uh
and we have the uh bioreactor bag hooked
on the output
of the rotia
and to start is the same so we
load the local pack and wash the local
pack back
and transfer the cells uh into
an intermediate bag we inject the
dynamics
and let it incubate on the rocker for 30
minutes
and after certain minutes this is uh
where it's different instead of
hook the bag on the dynamac we simply
load the
bees and the cell complex into the
chamber
and the unbound cells will be washed off
while the bone cells with bees form a
fluidized bed into the chamber
and then we watch this uh capture the
cells and bees and eject that
complex into the uh
incubator bioreactor
and uh if you look at the data here we
got pretty good
uh tcl isolation recovery
uh about 75 percent however the tcl
purity
is a little bit lower compared to
those methods using the dynamic
magnets we consider it's a
kind of a quick dirty way to isolate
t-cell
of course we are still optimizing this
process
however if you look at the t-cell purity
at the
d3 it catch up around
like 90 to 95 percent uh next step is
the wash
concentrate and buffer exchange before
elaboration
uh since this step and the uh
further downstream process process that
harvest and formulation both use
rotia and the process quite similar so i
will use
the one as example to illustrate
here the snapshot of cells undergo
wash concentrate and elaboration buffer
exchange
you can see the cell bed forming here
but there's not many cells shown here
but typically we would
process more cells than that and the
viability
from starting from the input to output
typically maintains we can see quite
comparable
and we can achieve on average 86 percent
of cell recovery in this step
after buffer exchange step
will go through elaboration to introduce
card genes into the t
cells so we have
two elaboration system available on the
left here is
neo elaboration system which is
aimed for research use r
d or a small scale um screening
and right here we have a large volume
elaboration xenon system
which can host one meal single shot or
five to 25 mil
flow through shot and we intentionally
design
both system to be compatible
which means once you identify
your perfect parameters
using neon you can seamlessly transition
these parameters
into the xenon
for manufacturing purpose
here the knocking data we generate to
use both neon and the xenon system
targeting three different low sides bit
acting
rev11a and track locus as you can see
the
knocking efficiency is quite
comparable across the board in both neon
and xenon system now we have the buffer
exchange
on the upstream and the elaboration
scene on the downstream how can we
connect these
two machines in order to achieve
automation
so here's the example of a very early
prototype we're thinking of
so basically you have a conical tube
sitting on a magnet
with the rnp and the dna on the tube
once the rotia process the cells it will
eject the cells into the chamber
and the cells got mixed with rnp and dna
and any residual dynamic is going to be
captured by the magnet
so essentially the solution is magnet
free
and then the xenon gonna draw the cell
rnp and dna complex into
the xenon evaporation chamber to do flow
through
elaboration the next step is to grow
more of the car t cells
to do that we have the optimizer serum
free medium
and the immune cell cell serum
replacement
which have been proven to provide
very good tcl expansion and high
viability
and more importantly this combination
involves the
enrichment of tcl memory phenotype
and the balanced cd4 and
cd8 ratio on the other hand
our high performer rocker system can
further facilitate
the robust tcl expansion as you can see
here
in combination of with our tcl media
the tcl fold expansion is comparable to
our competitor perfusion system
and outperform the static system
after cell expansion we do
buffer exchange formulation harvest
and the final step is to crowd preserve
those cartier cells in order to be
shipped
back to the hospital our control root
freezer
the crowd met has been extensively used
in the cell therapy
industry it provides repeatable and
consistent temperature
performance for the final product
and it allows user different consumables
it has a preset program for t-cells
and the user can sell their own
protocols as well
and on the data here we're showing
uh after saw the cell can
bend very well and the viability
basically uh before freeze and after saw
maintain above 90
so there you have it a complete closed
workflow solution for non-viral cartoon
manufacturing
and on top of that we are actively
develop the um direct away system in
order to integrate all these modules
uh into the system so that we can
achieve for
true automation
this is some official vision for cell
therapy manufacturing
first is modularity by creating a
modular
system uh we think it will
create building flexibility in your
process
so based on your own need you can swap
or switch different modules
and in in addition we think
modularity create efficiency
in terms of manufacturing for example
during the expansion phase
the rocker gonna expand for
several days right so
what we propose is you can simply seal
off the rocker
and still using the upstream module to
process
other patient samples the second is
standardization
not only we want to standardize the
process
step but also
uh by incoming colonizing the
uh reagent protocols
and established in process analytics
we want to provide the customers a
plugin plugin and play
so based on their individual steps
and third the fourth point is uh
compatibility and scalability we want
build a system that is compatible with
upstream and downstream
with a variety of different machineries
and of
of course the system has to uh comedy
for
scale out in autologous manufacturing
and
scale up for the allergenic
systems
i'll stop here and thank you for your
attention
thank you dr g for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
okay here we go what would you define
as the benefits in switching to a
semi-automated manufacturing platform in
this space
that's a good question so um i think the
first
and the most important thing by
switching to semi-automatic
you limit the human errors right
uh so it in return it creates
the consistency of the process
um and the other thing is it can
reduce your cost you know of the
training
of the uh clean room
uh everything else right so uh it's
definitely a benefit
thank you dr g our next question
will the xenon unit be gmp
yes so it is designed to be gmp
but i don't have the clear timeline for
it right now i have to
ask the product team i'll get back to
that
okay great thanks again dr g our next
question
when will the workflow solution be
available
so right now we are we have the complete
workflow solution but we are working
to be a as a customized solution for
uh different customers uh it's not a
commercially available yet
but if you're interested please contact
us individually
okay thanks again dr t our next question
can we use non-thermo-fisher platform on
the delta-v
system yeah the system uh
i mentioned here uh our main focus is
only thermal filter uh platforms
however on the database system you can
integrate other non-thermal filter
platforms
uh to do that you have to work with the
data we
creator which is emerson to
incorporate those platforms
hey thank you again dr chi the next
question we have
first what would you identify as the key
current bottlenecks and challenges
in car t-cell therapy manufacturing and
how have these issues evolved over
recent time
yeah definitely um i mean
uh the current state is
mostly opened uh manual
um process right so definitely uh we
think
uh create a closed system
is an immediate need so
by doing that you eliminate the
contamination risk
and maybe eliminate the clean room
need to reduce cost as well and
um the other side of it is the uh
manual process because this car t
process is really uh the incoming
material
is really uh varies
based on different patients so in order
to
make a success manufacturing you need to
create
consistency in the manufacturing process
so what we think is introducing the
automation uh
into this process will uh create a kind
of a standard
uh that you can do a quality control
um that in the end right you got like
very very consistent product out
okay thank you again dr chief our next
question
what are the key considerations to bear
in mind when one is looking to make this
switch
particularly at the early stage earlier
stages of development
what issues may arise and how should one
prepare to alleviate or address them
yeah that's another good question it's a
tough question so um
definitely when we think about the
design these platforms
uh uh compatibility is one issue right
so normally people will use
different company platform how we gonna
uh
you're gonna uh create a workflow that's
compatible
with different uh platform
that's one issue um the other thing i
was thinking is
more more of the uh
let's say um how
how you know you can reduce the
need of a multiple machines right so uh
i think in our example here
we can use rotia in multiple different
steps
that can reduce your your qualification
of your
uh uh of your
your your machine and also you know uh
with with
different with the similar machines you
reduce the training effort
so people get familiar with this machine
they have different protocols they can
load at different steps
that will create a lot of efficiency
okay thank you again dr chi our next
question
how important are tools that work across
multiple platforms and processes
and can you share any examples or
learnings from your own experiences
or workflow development success stories
incorporating such tools
yeah this is kind of a similar extension
to what i just mentioned
in the previous question so um
it is very important uh one example i
just mentioned the rotia you know you
can use the uh
in the pbmc isolation step and you can
use that in uh
you watch concentrate before elaboration
and also you can use it for final you
know formulation
so that it create a kind of a synergy
for one machine but you can do multiple
work
okay thank you dr chi let's see
looks like
we have a few more questions
how are you closing your system and what
makes it a closed
system
yeah that's a that's a tough question so
um
what we are right now using uh
by closing is using this as much as
uh say steroid uh
welding as well um so um
by doing that uh you know
of course right now at early stage we we
still
have to use the basic cabinets in in
order to prepare
some of the reagent but the whole
process once you load
um onto the machine uh
the only thing you do is do a steel weld
onto different parts or well done or
well off
all right well thank you so much dr g um
do you have any final comments for the
audience before we go today
and already i can't cover everything but
i would just want to
uh kind of re iterate in you know
what we think our uh
our vision for the uh geotherapy field
you know we
definitely want to uh create this kind
of a modular system
uh create a closed the
system and standardize the whole thing
we think this will drive the cost down
for
car team manufacturing and eventually
benefits the patient
thank you again dr yong cheng ji for
your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye